[Music]
so this entire video is going to be
about Tom
Cruz [__] shout outs to Tom Cruz that
I like that I like everybody here's a
fan of Tom Cruz I'm a h badass Man
favorite Tom Cruz movie go oh oh when he
was doing the Scientology dance Top Gun
that's not a movie Top Gun j m one in J
McGuire that's yeah that's probably it
Last
Samurai that's actually really goodan
that was good that was good Top Gun one
people believe in themselves again Top
Gun is to both both Top Guns Miss
impossible three all missions impossible
no the first one was so cool though
first one was cool for it
time better for its time actually two
sucks if you try to rewatch it you
rewatch it I did it's bad Top Gun one
and two that's fair oh Top Gun two oh
man the flight scenes dude that badass
dude I was watching this one interview
of him he they were asking him like okay
so you're like you know you're skyd
scuba uh certified scuba certified like
what what uh license don't you have and
he's like honestly I have a license to
fly at 747 almost all planes he goes I
even have my real estate license so he
just has like he a real estate he's just
into [__] he's got a license he's just
into [__] like licensed up yeah he could
he's got a class B license perks of
Scientology you can operate anywhere in
the sky on the floor on the sea I
actually did commercials for Scientology
yeah yeah I got like four commercials in
he did I went into the facility I went
into facility did you get cleared yeah
know I went into the facility in
Riverside it was crazy how much did you
pay to be a part of those commercials
how much did they pay me they paid me
like about 800 bucks commercial wow they
actually paid you not even right one was
in k toown for the and then I I really
asked him did you guys eat kids why is
everyone saying you guys eat kids it's
pretty question what they say to you
what they say you're so silly walked
away so they didn't say no they didn't
say
no what the [__] bro silly I was in
their Church in Riverside it was so it
was crazy cuz they have their own nobody
everyone who works there don't pay rent
cuz they all live in their little
facility it's a compound right so if you
go inside it's gate community it it's
just mountains and then gate that sounds
fun damn that's what I with my homies
that's what I did that's what I was like
you know I don't give up with my homies
but like different door rooms like a
compound yeah we got separation that
would be sick dude they're like 87y old
ladies you ever see hard
boil by John
L director of Miss too no I haven't is
that CH fat F you you would love that
movie every should Che I might have seen
it Tom Cruz was in mission impossible to
that's what I'm saying that's why I'm
like [__] I feel like mi2 was directed
by John Woo oh because of hard boil John
W is good he [__] good
D why why you talk about Tom Cruz though
cuz he's hot all right it's because he
actually recently signed a deal with
Warner Brothers to develop and produce
original and franchise films oh no but
he did this before with the mummy movie
oh that was yeah well now he's he's well
first of all what is he going to do
needs more [__] badass yeah is he
going to do like Bugs Bunny or something
Warner Brothers Bugs Bunny Bugs Bunny
Daffy ducks Tom Cruz is going to do Bugs
Bunny specifically you don't think he's
going do a Bugs Bunny Movie he's not
going to bring back anime an might be a
Daffy thing oh maybe he'll do like a
Space Jam maybe yeah Top Gun three Tom
Cruz Space Jam
O Okay Top Gun three is in the world Top
Gun three Top Gun is now Daffy Duck oh
[__] as Ace he's short too Daffy Duck as
Ace okay Marvin the Martian yeah I love
him combine the [__] basketball movie
with Top Gun and and the whole cast of
The Looney Tunes I'm watching it me too
it's called top fun that's that's tight
that's tight and they got to play
basketball with the
Jets that's what I was waiting for if
you can't hit the
basketball that's all I got my bad no no
no I was
there the world with you fre subject guy
not so much predicates I freaking lost
it so he's going to be part of like
World creation and like franchise
creation that's crazy and he's going to
star in all of them cuz that's Tom Cruz
he's going to produce and star them and
it's a non-exclusivity contract so he's
still going to be doing his stuff with
Paramount and anything else that he's
already got Legacy for of course he
comes out with leverage on the deal go
so much leverage like a billion dollar
contract or something D sounds insane
Tom Cruz is the last we fing the last we
he's next level yes he's like super
super super short he does it all the way
he's bwan style he's [__] hanging on
the side of a [__] airplane playing
and like he doesn't have to and they put
a stupid camera in his face he doesn't
have to they could CGI it would look the
same it doesn't matter but it's all
about the story it's about the story
bwan deprived himself of food water
anything he couldn't get hard he had
headaches for three months just so he
could win two swords that's why Fresno
that's it to to conquer Fresno bwan
started himself Tom Cruz is that way
except that he does it for larger scale
things but less swords but yeah and it's
and it's Hollywood Los Angeles not
Fresno exactly that's a more important
city did you see that [__] motorcycle
ramp [__] he did oh bro and he did six
of them I know and he goes bet I could
do better and I'm like they all look the
same exactly the [__] the bike longer
and each time I'm so cheap I'm like oh
it's kill $1,000 a bike oh my God is he
just throwing away bikes every single
they don't have a parachute for the bike
no they don't have a parachute for the
bike but it's you know it's a [__]
million dollar movie you going $3,000
dirt bike make sure it's just start the
bike is probably like 3,000 bucks yeah
yeah and they painted black you know VFX
charge of it I'll make I could use
crypto I'll make 90 grand with it in
four months but you got to you got to
let me do it I also heard he had like
pages and pages of waivers in case he
passes and they already have multiple
scripts in case he passes how do they
re-edit the film if he doesn't make
those so all those things are in
discussion and insurance yeah insurance
it's Stakes are high yeah that's [__]
it's like Paul Walker but then you also
got to remember when he's an executive
producer of these films and these films
are loved in like China this Fool's bank
roll has got to be insane they don't
even have to put Chinese guys in it they
don't probably 20 uh last 20 money
handlers Tom Cruz has worked at Warner
Brothers in the past but it's been a
decade since he appeared in the studi
edge of tomorrow okay oh yeah he did he
did other Warner Brothers releases such
as Magnolia is that the future thing
where he just keeps resetting yeah no
Joe no it is yeah it is I've seen it
that movie is sick and and they're
trying to convince him to do Edge of
Tomorrow too by the way oh I've seen it
well the OG but the surp the surprise
goes away after you've seen it one time
the OG title was live repeat yeah it
does or no all you need is kill and then
change it to live by repeat which gave
away the game I think the Edge of
Tomorrow is a s title yeah yeah it's a
good movie it's a great and Emily Blunt
is fine in that [__] so fine so was she
doing this [__] like a dolphin oh my
Lord I'm like yo I can't have you I
can't do high five cuz I don't remember
what high five I don't want to give you
high five I don't remember imagine a
woman sweating so hot and then arm
imagine this you ever been to SeaWorld
yes you ever see a dolphin get out of
the water real quick and like good
[__] analog that's what she's doing
Shamu but then imagine you're in a world
where you want to [__] the dolphin
that's what it's like
God no not the dolphin no no not the
dolphin Emily Blunt
yeah dolphin that was a dolphin dolphin
was my entry andem we Blunt The Finisher
yes if you guys could ask Tom Cruz to
make a another movie what would you guys
say Jerry McGuire 2 oh I wouldn't say
that but on have to be there too this
time it'll be about the Clippers
basketball team yeah it wasn't about a
team it was about a relationship with an
agent you know no but then you got to do
something different what's the
difference about pointing across a room
and be I love black people part two okay
okay okay hey cool hey Top Gun Top Gun
Top Gun Top Gun three what's happening
guys top really so yeah you want Top Gun
four then yeah I would want top I would
want the last Last Samurai oh like a mod
to Last Samurai I don't know they should
have had a sequel it was a success it
was the first Warrior after The Last
Samurai but they killed all of his
homies yeah they killed his brothers
yeah he he should just come back so it
should be Revenge Revenge of the Last
Samurai oh that's you know what I really
liked I like American maid I forgot
about that one I love that was fun plays
Barry seal yeah yeah that was a good one
I'd like him to do more of those ones
you know the movie was suck but was fun
because of him Jack Jack Reacher was
actually sick and the sequel too but it
was kind of like a not good movie but he
made it so entertaining I liked it I'm I
think I'm trash though minority minority
report was good Minority Report was good
that's Spielberg right what's the one
with the Jamie Fox was it collateral not
coll collateral damage that was pretty
good just collateral
damage her name I think he I think he
could stop I think he could stop Mission
Impossible yeah yeah yeah exactly
stopping Mission Impossible the next
one's the last one yeah dead reckoning
part two is no but like I don't think he
even needs to do the next one he it's
already done like I think it's done done
they stopped filming yeah you're not
getting it man they stopped filming last
year I don't think they should release
it at all oh I actually it's just done
they should just like done I feel like
they might as well release yeah they're
not going to really listen to a [__]
guy from a YouTube channel actually
culture doesn't need it they're probably
going to just release it actually it's
going to hurt it's going to hurt Society
I will say dead reckoning part one was
like mid if he doesn't go on a cables
and then get two Ines away from a laser
I don't want to watch it dude what if it
was a you know I am Legend 2 is coming
out such an old
what if I am Legend 2 Tom Cruz appears
but is it zombie Tom Cruz but is it
zombie Tom Cruz no just both survivals
and then the sequel dead reckoning part
two once Tom KRS come out he takes off
the [__] thing Will
Smith and then he smacks a zombie smacks
a zombie hey but if they're the last two
zombie zomb if they're the last two
remaining humans does that mean they're
homosexual and then they have to [__] to
repopulate the Earth right yeah one of
them repopulate but yeah gain ovaries
guess you can now everyone knows that if
you just claim that you're a certain way
now you're making it a political try to
kill each other that's true that's even
better that's more manly I am the legend
I am oh that's a good dialogue that's
good dialog I Am Legend no I am I am the
legend no I am the
one but don't you think it's time for a
more diverse person than Tom Cruz and a
lesbian yes we need a different isn't
closeted gay or no is
that no that's BR no that's Brett pit
that's Bret har about Bret
Hart the hit man heart yeah he's from
Calgary Al who has ever went Tom no wait
I'm thinking of Brett The Hitman heart
whoops yeah sha Michael's badass hey
Shawn Michael The Heartbreak Kid dude
did you know that everyone thinks that
decaprio all those girls are just his
beards but really he's a gay gay I I
haven't heard that no I haven't heard
that all right well who told you that
got the tabloids bro one more rumor
spread just one more rumor D I already
SL who else is Gage I already beats it
up in town and out of town well this one
might not be surprising huh P Diddy P
didd is gay oh a th% we all know that a
th% yeah for sure Cat Williams said that
you wanted to get sucked off cat William
is not the only one who said that Cent
everybody 50 Cent pound his ass dude
yeah and there's guys that's giv it up
to him they said P Diddy they're like P
didy loves to party loves to party who's
giving up to P didy ask 50 c it's all
over his Instagram okay Tom Cruz Tom
Cruz to give it up to
P huge breaking news here at JK news I'm
just going to ask
Curtis